>> AMERICA HAS 18 MORE
MONTHS OF ELECTION AWESOMENESS
YET TO LOOK FORWARD TO,
BUT IN BRITAIN THE BALLOTS
ARE ALL COUNTED.
SO I WENT ACROSS THE POND TO
SEE HOW THEY ROCKED THE VOTE.
CHEERIO.
DEMOCRACY IN THE U.K.,
JORDAN KLEPPER REPORTS ON
THE ROAD TO THE-- WAIT,
THAT'S WHERE THE PRIME
MINISTER LIVES?
>> THE BRITISH PEOPLE HAVE
JUST ENDURED ONE OF THE
LONGEST ELECTION SEASONS IN
THEIR HISTORY.
IT IS OVERBLOWN, IN MY
OPINION.
>> IT'S JUST GONE ON AND ON AND
ON.
>> IN FACT, I'VE STOPPED
LISTENING TO THE RADIO SINCE
IT ALL BEGAN.
>> I SAT DOWN WITH ELECTION
EXPERT KATIE GHOSE WHO MUST BE
EXHAUSTED FROM THE YEARS OF
NONSTOP CAMPAIGNING.
>> WELL, THE FORMAL CAMPAIGN
KICKED OFF AT THE END OF
MARCH.
>> WHAT?
>> OUR CAMPAIGN PERIOD
LASTS FOR JUST SIX WEEKS.
>> SIX WEEKS OF ELECTION?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HOW DO YOU SPEND $5
BILLION IN SIX WEEKS?
>> WELL, NO BODY WOULD EVER
BE ALLOWED TO SPEND $5
BILLION.
I THINK THAT BRITISH PEOPLE
WOULD BE HORRIFIED BY THE SHEER
SUMS AND THE LENGTH OF TIME
OVER WHICH MONEY IS SPENT ON
ELECTIONS IN AMERICA.
>> HORRIFIED MEANS GOOD HERE,
RIGHT?
LIKE IT'S SICK, LIKE IT'S
TERRIBLE, LIKE IT'S DOPE.
>> NO, THAT'S BAD.
WE HAVE QUITE STRICT
REGULATIONS ON SPENDING
HERE.
EACH PARTY WILL HAVE A TOTAL
SPENDING LIMIT OF AROUND $30
MILLION POUNDS.
>> PER WEEK.
>> FOR THE FORMAL CAMPAIGN
PERIOD.
>> SERIOUSLY?
THAT'S ONLY LIKE 15 MILLION
DOLLARS.
OR ABOUT ONE 50th THE AMOUNT A
SINGLE AMERICAN CANDIDATE MIGHT
SPEND.
HOW ON EARTH DO YOU RUN A
CAMPAIGN WITH BULL [BLEEP]
MONEY?
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT PARLIAMENTARY
CANDIDATE, MAAJID NAWAZ.
>> WE'RE LOOKING FOR
IS VOTES AND NOT MONEY.
SO WHAT WE DO IS THROUGH YEARS
OF CAMPAIGNING --
>> WAIT, SAY THAT AGAIN.
>> WE'RE LOOKING FOR VOTES,
NOT MONEY.
>> LISTEN, MY TOTAL
CAMPAIGN.
I'M RAISING 5,000 POUNDS.
>> AND 5,000 POUNDS GOES
JUST AS FAR AS YOU WOULD
EXPECT.
>> I'M ROBIN, I'M MAAJID'S
CAMPAIGN ORGANIZER.
>> YOU'RE THE CAMPAIGN
ORGANIZER?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU MEAN YOUR DAD IS THE
CAMPAIGN ORGANIZER.
>> NO, I AM.
>> YOU ARE RUNNING THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> YEAH, WELL, WITH THE HELP
OF THE LOCAL PARTY, YEAH.
>> DO YOU MIND IF I ASK HOW
OLD YOU ARE.
>> I'M 23.
>> YOU'RE 23.
>> BUT I'M A CANDIDATE
MYSELF AS WELL FOR AN
ADJACENT SEAT.
>> YOU ARE A CANDIDATE FOR A
MUSTACHE FOR THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS.
>> THIS LACK OF RESOURCES
WAS HEARTBREAKING.
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, NOT A
KEEPER.
MONEY'S TIGHT, THANK YOU.
LUCKILY, IN AMERICA, WE
HAVE A LITTLE THING CALLED
FREEDOM, THANKS TO THE
SUPREME COURT'S RULING ON
CITIZEN'S UNITED MONEY IS
CONSIDERED SPEECH.
AND IT'S FREE TO EXPRESS
ITSELF USING THOUGHT
PROVOKING POLITICAL
ADVERTISING LIKE THESE
ACTUAL ADS.
>> I WANT TO USE MY GLOCK TO
BLOW YOUR BALLS OFF.
>> BUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
POLITICAL TV ADS ARE BANNED
IN THE U.K.
SO THE PARTIES MUST USE ANOTHER
WAY TO TAKE DOWN THEIR
OPPONENT.
>> BILLBOARDS ARE ALLOWED IN
THE U.K. SO THAT IS REALLY
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THE
NEGATIVE ADS.
>> LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT,
THEY'RE GOING TO ATTACK
THEIR POLITICAL FOES IN THE
SAME MEDIUM YOU WOULD USE TO
ADVERTISE CHER AT THE
HILTON?
>> THE ONE THAT REALLY
CAUGHT PEOPLE'S ATTENTION
THIS TIME AROUND WAS ONE
PORTRAYING THE LEADER OF THE
LABOUR PARTY ED MILIBAND IN
THE POCKET OF ALEX SALMOND
HE'S IS THE LEADER OF A SMALLER
PARTY -- THE SCOTTISH
NATIONAL PARTY.
>> AND?
>> IT'S SHOWING ONE POLITICIAN
IN THE POCKET OF ANOTHER.
>> WHAT IS NEGATIVE ABOUT THAT?
>> THEY FELT THAT THAT WAS A
REALLY NEGATIVE THING TO DO.
>> NO ONE IS SUCKING OFF
HITLER IN THIS SITUATION?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT PEOPLE
WANT --
>> I MEAN, YOU BASICALLY HAD A
PRIME
MINISTER WHO DID THAT,
AM I RIGHT?
NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN SLAM.
>> WE WOULD NEVER HAVE
ANYTHING OF THAT KIND OF
NATURE.
I THINK THAT --
>> GOD, IT'S LIKE THESE
PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN HEAR ME.
DAMMIT.
IN FACT, NO ONE WAS
LISTENING.
BUT I KNEW THE BEST PLACE TO
TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT NO
ONE WANTED TO HEAR IS ON
CABLE TV SO I WALKED THROUGH
THE HALLOWED HALLS OF BBC
INTERNATIONAL TO KNOCK SOME
SENSE INTO THE BRITISH
PUBLIC.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT
ALL.
>> I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU, YOU
GUYS ARE MESSING IT ALL UP.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU NEED SOME AMERICAN STYLE
POLITICS IN YOUR
BRITISH STYLE WHATEVER YOU
CALL IT.
>> SO WHAT WOULD YOU INJECT TO
IMPROVE WHAT WE'VE GOT?
>> DOLLAH DOLLAH BILLS, Y'ALL.
OR I THINK YOU CALL THEM POUNDS
OR COINS, YOU NEED MONEY.
>> RIGHT. RIGHT, BUT WHAT ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT ED MILIBAND,
THE LEADER OF THE OPPOSITION --
>> WHAT? THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
YELL
OR FIGHT OR MAKE IT
INTERESTING AT ALL.
[BLEEP] THE BBC.
I WAS GOING TO GET THIS
MESSAGE OUT USING THE
BIGGEST, MOST EXTRAVAGANT
PLATFORM.
LEGALLY ALLOWED IN BRITAIN.
WE SHALL OVERCOME.
WE BEING THE MONEY.
HAVE YOU GUYS CONSIDERED LETTING
MONEY SPEAK IN YOUR
ELECTIONS?
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO PAY
ATTENTION TO.
LET MONEY TALK.
>> NICE BIKE, YOU WANK!
>> THANK YOU.
>> CHANGE WAS A COMING.